on wednesday heather ran three miles in
30 minutes
if she ran for 45 minutes at this rate
on thursday how far did heather run on
thursday
let's just think about what that rate is
so the rate is going to be equal to the
distance
the distance she traveled per time
and this is going to be equal to let's
see she traveled three miles
she traveled 3
miles in 30 minutes
in 30
minutes
and so you could simplify 3 over 30 is
the same thing this is the same thing as
1 10
1 10 of a mile
of a mile
per minute
per minute
that's her rate now that's not what
they're asking for they're saying if she
went at this rate for 45 minutes how far
would she run well just multiply them so
45
minutes
times
times one mile or one tenth of a mile
per minute i can just copy and paste
that right over there so times that copy
and paste
what are we going to get
well it's going to be 45 times 1 10 or
it's the same thing as 45 divided by 10
that's going to be equal to 4.5
4.5 and then the minutes cancel out
minutes in the numerator min in the
denominator 4.5
4.5
miles another way to think about it and
this might even be an easier way to
think about it is
well she's going at the same rate if
you're going from 30 minutes on one day
to 45 minutes on the next day you're
increasing you're increasing your
minutes by 50
30 plus half of 30 30 plus 15 is 45 so
the distance you travel is going to be
increasing by 50 percent so fifty
percent increase
on three would get you two half of fifty
percent of three is one point five you
add that to three gets you to four point
five
so either way you wanna tackle it